[Music]  right that thought of fives been out  just one week it has already made over a  billion dollars yeah yeah it's a  downside though I was playing Grand  Theft Auto earlier today I think making  all that money has had a negative effect  on one of the main characters check it  out ah these Brazilian cherry oak planks  feel great on my Gucci loafers hmm  blended money my favorite normal rules  don't apply to me above the law excuse  me don't call the police I own them I'm  rich I'm rich I'm rich you're not who  private helicopter don't mind if I do  boo a trailer park attention white trash  I am better than you  Malibu looks so pretty from the air look  at all my beachfront property yeah I  think I'll go land on Spielberg's house  [Applause]  [Music]  the rich guy died  [Applause]